le 11 mars dernier il ya trois mois le
premier ministre françois legault
exprimait déjà ses principales
inquiétudes par rapport au corps en un
virus la pire chose qui pourrait arriver
le ceux qui le virus se propage dans des
centres de personnes âgées mais en
rétrospective on réalise qu au moment de
prononcer ces mots il était peut-être
déjà trop tard pour éviter le pire
en analysant les données on constate
combien le québec a d'abord été victime
de son calendrier scolaire
la distanciation social n'était même pas
encore à l'ordre du jour et des gens la
semaine de relâche inquiétait le docteur
arruda
c'est que les coques sont venus le
contenu reste amasser des gens qui ont
été voyage particulièrement pendant la
semaine de relâche dans certains pays au
québec le congé scolaire a eu lieu du 2
au 7 mars et plusieurs québécois en ont
profité pour voyager
c'était avant qu'ottawa recommande de
cesser les voyages non-essentiels
exactement deux semaines après la fin de
la relâche le 21 mars le nombre de cas
s'est mis à grimper en flèche
rappelons que deux semaines c'est le
temps qu'il faut pour développer les
symptômes
le gouvernement met alors le québec sur
pause et le docteur arruda martèle qu'il
faut aplatir la courbe cardon l'applet 6
1 mais les a d'abord un plateau
pendant que la santé publique tentent de
limiter les dégâts provoqués par la
semaine de relâche dans le réseau de la
santé on commence à manquer
d'équipements de protection
aujourd'hui être clair je vais vous dire
la vérité pour certains équipements on
en or pour 3 à 7 jours au début avril le
québec doit se battre avec les états
unis pour trouver des masques au même
moment le virus comment ses ravages dans
les chs ld on découvre d'abord le film
d'horreur à la résidence privée et ron
des dizaines de patients morts
abandonnés par le personnel qui a
déserté demain avant une enquête longue
je dois être brute d'un pis j'ai le goût
de pôle d'annonay même où je pense qu a
priori le ignore la grosse négligence
chu où elle réside en seine mais ce
n'est que la pointe de l'iceberg
les déplacements de personnel d'un
centre à l'autre ont propagé le virus
des dizaines de crs elle dit sont
contaminées en avril puis en mai le
nombre de morts explose
82 % des décès viennent des chs ld ou
des résidences pour personnes âgées
lorsqu'elle ce virus rend dans une
résidence pour aînés
c'est un peu comme mettre le feu dans le
foin tout brûle rapidement depuis trois
mois la corrida fait plus de 5000 morts
au québec le taux de mortalité par cent
mille habitants est supérieur à
l'ontario plus élevés qu'aux états unis
dépasse celui de la france il est même
supérieure à l'italie ce qui montre à
quel point le virus
a durement affecté le québec ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal